six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number who's our next
caller oh uh hello yeah what's your name
and where you're calling from hey this
is Paul from Ohio Paul great to hear
from you was very much was what is going
on with Lewis is he coming back to do
any kind of like guest segment or
anything at any time
I don't know Lewis is he is heading
towards the south of the United States
in mere days to start exploring where
his future home may be as you'll
remember former producer Lewis left the
show in search of more rural and warmer
life situations so yeah I mean I would
be thrilled for Lewis to Skype in one
day when he settled down south and tell
us what he's doing and where he is I saw
him last weekend and he's only just
beginning this new adventure in his life
Paul dude do you think you're gonna have
him on at least a little bit yeah like
like I said I would be thrilled for
Lewis to Skype it at some point I
actually had the idea on election night
that maybe he should Skype in that day
but even though it was election night
and you'd think that he's at least
somewhat politically active he has doing
trivia instead he was not unable to join
us on election night because he was
playing trivia while watching election
results yes so that's what's going on as
far as far as that's concerned Paul did
he leave the show for like personal
reasons or like were you guys
disagreeing about stuff at any point or
was it just you know he wanted to move
no no like like we like we said Louis
was was sad to be leaving the show but
he wanted to live somewhere more rural
he doesn't like cities and he also
doesn't like cold weather so that was
what what brought him I'm feeling like
this call is Groundhog's Day in some way
but it is I know something that's super
super important to the audience Pat
there's also about like a 10 to 12
minute video of Louis explaining his
reasons for leaving the show I would
definitely check that out on YouTube
yeah thank you so much for the call
really appreciate it